welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question i'm back baby this is
the show that gives you too much
information about the endless stream of
questions that exist in endless
timelines within endless universes my
name is eric voss i'm here today with mt
what's going on eric
dude it's a special episode special
episode day special edition a big
question because this is our 100th
episode
[Music]
and to celebrate that we asked all of
you to send us your burning questions
that we can try to answer 100 questions
for this 100th episode and boy did y'all
deliver but yo yo timeout time to
timeout shouldn't philip be here for
this super special 100th episode of big
question that is a good question mt uh
actually now that you mention it i have
not seen philip ever since we sent him
through that quantum time vortex i
wonder
if he might show up to help answer some
of these questions
no
i don't think i will
oh well we don't really have much time
so we gotta get started we're gonna get
through as many as we can hopefully
we'll get to 100 here we go question one
who's stronger hydra or the ten rings um
ten rings seems pretty powerful they've
been around for a long long time but in
a digital age i feel like hydra i think
like these days in the mcu i would say
the tin rings but you know
hydra's coming up they're coming up i
hydra i mean if you are if you have a
home with wi-fi zola is gonna beat you
every every day of the week uh question
two if the mcu ever includes the one
above all who do you want to play them
empty
i would say
morgan freeman you gotta have morgan
freeman he's got oh
i'm god i always think it's just kevin
feige oh my god that'd be great that'd
just be super meta
question three how long until marvel
crosses over with dc have you not
watched our new rockstars videos
recently there was a superman shout out
in an eternals trailer so it has already
begun that's superman with the cape and
you're shooting laser beams out of your
eyes um but are we ever gonna see
superman shake hands with uh with
captain marvel or something like that i
hope not i don't care
i really hope that they do settle their
differences but it's highly unlikely
dude i really want to see it i want to
see that spider-man superman team up
inside the comics
left on that crossover not interested
uh before what would the real aftermath
be to hulk eating too much taco bell
would he blow a house down with a fart
or more likely launch himself into the
air uh i think he wouldn't know when to
stop eating taco bell and we'd get a
what if episode three scenario yeah
that's exactly what i was gonna say
five shuri references disneyland and
black panther with the opening of
avengers campus at disney california
adventure does it exist in mcu canon ah
i look this up i don't think adventures
campus is technically mcu cannon the way
galaxy's edge i think is technically
star wars canon avengers campus is not
however disneyland as a location uh does
exist in the mcu because shuri mentioned
disneyland and black panther says i
thought the first time you take me to
california you would take me to
coachella or disneyland
when you said you would take me to
california for the first time
i thought you meant coachella
or disneyland so it doesn't exist in
that sense um empty this is a good
question for you how powerful are the
ten rings in comparison to other marvel
weapons like cap shield or mjolnir oh
that's a good question well i feel like
that has yet to be seen because we don't
know the material sure that the rings
are made of because it's like the super
ancient material that no one's ever seen
but i think that it stacks up pretty
well against cap shield and mjolnir
because it seems just like a very
ancient um
just rock yeah i think uh the way that
mjolnir and cap shield are kind of like
there were checks on each other i think
all three of these things would be kind
of equal if you you could use them to
deflect off each other
but
yeah exactly exactly question seven
could ultravision take on the tva could
he ever enter the tva uh they have that
robot guard so i don't know but
ultravision we're talking ultron
infinity that guy has no boundaries
really so probably i mean i don't know i
mean like his infinity stones probably
wouldn't work inside the tva but he's
still pretty yolked himself to take down
a bunch of like regular ass people so
it'd be fine i'm gonna venture to say no
i think the tva seems like a pretty
powerful constant in a in a pocket
dimension they have that robot guard at
their checkpoint uh you're right
infinity stones don't work in there i
think like with even with their analog
uh computers they'd they'd be able to
stop them in its tracks okay
stop you violated the law um similar
question would wanda and dr strange be
powerless in the tva
uh
i think i'd have to say yes i think they
seem to have a magic barrier to where
like uh sylvia as a sorceress could not
use her power loki as a sorcerer could
not use his power so yeah i i don't
think they'd be able to get very far
there yeah i don't think they're power
sources i think their power sources are
directly linked to the universes that
they live in so yeah uh number nine will
this adam warlock be like dr
frankenferder's rocky creation in the
rocky horror picture uh more than hope
than a question let's do the time warp
again i totally agree um i would love if
that's the case i i want him just to be
like a weird cocoon boy what do you
think empty i've i've never seen rocky
horror picture shows oh you gotta get on
that
i don't know how to answer you you have
to get on that empire it's a classic
well similar question number 10 what
will warlock's role be in the guardians
of the galaxy vol 3. yeah i want him to
be just a creepo who like every 11
minutes has to put himself back in the
cocoon and sleep for two hours
that's what i wanted to do
hilarious i think it's gonna be aisha's
lap dog for a little bit and then just
be like i'm free i'm my own boy i'm a
real boy just like pinocchio style
question 11 who would win in a fight god
emperor doom or ultravision who do you
think empty god emperor doom easily that
means too much power i agreed uh
question 12 what live-action spider-man
would win in a fist fight uh
i feel like andrew garfield has a height
advantage but tom holland has been doing
a lot of like stunts and flips and
gymnastics um i i still think andrew
garfield
you know what i i i'm gonna give it to
tom holland because that dude is yolked
that little man is yoked he could fight
yeah
okay do you think nicholas cage will
come back to play ghost writer no
no no i think his ghost writing days are
done question 14 who should be cast as
ghost writer i thought gabriel luna did
a really good job in agents of shield
but i don't think they will cast him but
i do like the idea they brought in a
latino actor to play the role i hope
they would keep that in mcu i just think
there's a nice fit there with like uh uh
like the fact that mephisto is tied in
with the character i i just think i
liked that choice
yeah i think i kind of want to go with
you know this is a fan favorite choice
but daryl from the walking dead um
blanking on his name now oh yeah yeah
yeah i don't know what
oh yeah norman reedus right i think it'd
be great
he'd be crazy he'd be great yeah you're
just thinking because he raised that
motorcycle around
let's see 15 do you think
joker should be in the reeves batman
verse hard no
no
no no no no
hard no
hard notes please dear god can we take a
break from the joker you know what i i'm
going to agree with you because i really
do want him to tackle calendar man next
because calendar man would be great for
that university
agreed i agree quarterback
yeah there's a lot of ways he can go 16.
where is robin in the dceu dead dead bag
of dead r.i.p
uh 17. could michael keaton actually be
playing thomas wayne maybe i think just
haven't played bruce wayne if you're
gonna bring it thomas wayne bring in
jeffrey dean morgan yeah there's no
reason to do that yeah i think he's just
straight up playing bruce wayne 18 who
would win in a fight between the
avengers in the justice league i mean
uh the avenger depends on who's on the
avengers do you mean the six og avengers
in the mcu
because if that's the case the justice
league for sure because they have
superman but whoever's on the adventures
now you have like captain marvel on the
team maybe doctor strange maybe scarlet
witch yeah yeah like if you have people
if you have nexus level beans on the
avengers they're gonna win they can
change warp reality 100 yeah if wanda's
on the team then it's game over for
superman easy yeah 19 are you gonna
cover the boys season three uh we hope
so
hope so i'm looking forward to it 20. do
you think the lando disney plush show
will follow childish gambino his name is
donald glover but oh
young lando or old lando his name's
billy d williams uh post episode nine
when he asked that girl if he wants to
find out more about her past i think
this series would be more interesting to
follow young lando because he has all
these adventures in his past that uh
from all like the expanded universe
novels i mean what do you think oh yeah
it's going to be young lando like they
they very very much set up a lot of
stuff in solo and i feel like yeah
orlando is the next step for them with
uh donald glover so it's going to be
young random 21 now that fortress vader
and mustafar are in the mcu do you think
the watcher will intervene in the
mandalorian boba fett shows
no it wasn't even confirmed that they're
in the mcu it just the art looks like it
but so many people would be so annoyed
with that and like justifiably so like
let's keep those universes separate 22
when will we see grogu again uh probably
mando's season three right they're
shooting it now yeah hopefully we'll see
it by the end of 2022. yeah groga is a
big selling point for this for that
whole franchise so we're gonna see him
again 23. what is your favorite line
from star wars what's yours empty um
a lot of great lines
the only line that's popping into my
head is another happy landing
from obi-wan kenobi yeah he's got i mean
he's infinitely quotable in episode
three hello there
um
even the younglings
you were like a brother
you're a brother you weren't like a
brother i have the high grounds burger i
think my favorite line is uh never tell
me the odds it's classic right never
tell me yes it's just great amazing
let's see 24 is jar jar binks truly a
dark lord of the sith
yes yeah that's my favorite fan theory
and i will go
why do stormtroopers wear armor and die
after one blast shot they don't my
friend that's not how i know it seems
that way but the way the stormtrooper
armor works is it it disperses the blast
to just be it absorbs the shock but that
shock knocks them on their butts but it
prevents them from dying at least that's
how
stormtrooper armor is supposed to work i
know we've seen like uh things go
through stormtrooper armor maybe in
later things but originally in the
original trilogy it's like a shop shock
absorbing thing that knocks them on
their ass but it doesn't kill them uh i
think that's wrong eric i think the
empire only uh hires people with bad
hearts one shot yeah just knocks them
yeah put them out of their misery that's
right
26 which star wars character would you
most likely see crossover in the mcu
none of them i don't want to see that
happen ever please no
yeah no thank you huge fan of it myself
yeah it's just the
everything that makes the character
magical and specific to their world is
lost when you bring them into another uh
franchise this isn't like bringing over
different spider verses that i get but
like bringing in star wars i don't want
to see a lightsaber collide with a uh a
captain america shield wait
i'm gonna answer this i'm gonna say babu
frick i just love baboo frick from
episode 9.
he can be he can be in everything that's
fine that's okay
uh 27 who is the who is the better
resurrecting villain emperor palpatine
or ross i'll go oh razzle gold rouse
easy easy 100 times razzle gould yeah i
mean palpatine should not have
resurrected i think somehow he did eric
somehow yeah who would win if star wars
and marvel fought i don't know what this
means
[Laughter]
if like the title cards fought if all
the characters in star wars bought all
the character in marvel i mean if that's
the case all the characters in marvel
would win we have like several gods and
nexus beings who could transcend
realities such rules have not been
established in marvel or in star wars
will you cover scream five i don't know
maybe
if enough people want us to i guess i'll
watch it
yeah question 30 will you ever break
down harry potter i used to want to i
honestly don't want to anymore i
rewatched those movies in the past year
i think they have not aged all that well
i think the author of that franchise
kind of torpedoed it uh and it's hard to
watch it now and not make fun of how bad
the acting is by the kids i'm sorry
i'm just not interested also harry
potter fans kind of suck they kind of
suck
you guys were real to me when i
did fantastic beasts videos i'm not
interested in giving you guys it i think
there's a lot of you who are nice but
after i watch cursed child is one of the
worst days of my life watching that play
i'm not i don't like the franchise
anymore i'm done with it i'm done with
it i think it's trash
damn i'll read those books with my kids
but i
i guess you could say harry potter broke
down itself i agree uh will you cover
halloween kills um again maybe i i like
covering horror stuff and we did some
videos on the first halloween not the
first uh the 2018 halloween but
yeah i don't know maybe it's already
kind of come out right uh yes i don't
think we will uh 32 are you are we going
to get some kind of lord of the rings
breakdown one day i hope that is one
like past series that like oh i am
waiting i am waiting for the rainy uh a
couple months
honestly we're just gonna have so much
new content coming out in 2022 2023 and
beyond i don't think we'll ever really
have that rainy day
um
and if new rockstars ever really does it
i don't know if i'm gonna have the time
to devote to do it like that would have
to be my only job the only project i
could spend you'd have to convince
phillip to let me not do anything else
for the channel for a month and only
focus on those lord of the rings things
and then yes i could do it wait are they
referring to the movies or the new show
coming out ooh uh i think in either case
probably
i assume they're talking about like the
classic lord of the rings things but
yeah i think when the new one comes out
there's a better chance that we'll cover
the new one than the old one okay do you
think you all at new rock stars will
ever cover anime movies or shows such as
attack on titan uh jiu jitsu kaizen
my hero
etc
i want to
that's another one that's like on our
list of things to get to what do you
think i'm a huge ammo i'm a huge anime
fan myself so like it would be great to
cover like the new anime shows and stuff
and you could give me a reason to really
get back into anime because i feel like
i you know kind of dropped off a little
bit but my hero academia fantastic show
if you love superheroes go watch my hero
academia it's literally one of the best
superhero shows ever and also yeah i'm
invincible but that's not an anime okay
yeah
34 what advice would you give to a
fellow film buff who is just starting
out in making film related content on
youtube i would recommend i i don't mean
to just by this stop using the term film
buff maybe i think it's just a weird
term
uh and i only say this because like one
people who
would be considered film buffs or not
buff
and it's not really a buff it's not
really like a muscle
um
we're all very weak also like
everyone i know who has ever called
themselves the film buff
they don't really know that much about
movies they like to think that they do
because among their friends on their
trivia night team they seem like they do
but here's what i'll say uh if you are
gonna make film analysis on youtube
remember that there's nothing easier in
the world than to make like
an a dis to find something wrong about a
movie it's very easy to find plot holes
and mistakes in any movie uh the more
challenging worthwhile endeavor is to
find
reasons to appreciate it even the worst
movie in the world still has like
craft that went into it uh so be that
guy don't be the guy who just makes his
snide parody videos where he's playing
two versions of himself making very easy
jokes and getting millions of views out
of it
[Music]
[Applause]
my advice i feel would be to just do
something different like don't do what
everybody else is doing find out what is
different about yourself and like you in
the way that you make content and then
just
be different be unique i feel like
that's what people are looking for
uh good advice uh do you play video
games i do not currently i don't have
time to do you play video games i love
video games i'm like i just play
replayed miles morales and had a blast
it was amazing so big gamer over here
similar question 36 have you guys ever
considered doing more easter egg
breakdowns of any more marvel or dc
games yes we do have a lot of uh things
in the works right now where we want to
start doing more uh gaming related
content so stay tuned for that let's see
who is your favorite marvel character
that we have not seen in the mcu yet uh
doctor doom i would say i want a proper
car knack because like karnak is my
favorite marvel character of all time
but like in terms of
potential mcu i really want to see
death's head and i think that death's
head could be that character that james
gunn is uh teasing for his oh uh holiday
special because i really i just really
wanted to be that because like i know he
really loves robots and death robot uh
38 which character in the mcu is the
most depowered compared to their comic
book counterpart ooh i would say hulk
right hulk's been kind of done dirty in
the mcu we saw one thunderclap in the
2008 film but like we've never we so
rarely get to see him hulk out and i get
it it's expensive to vfx that character
compared to everyone else but yeah i
would say hulk seems pretty de-powered
compared to what he is in the comics
yeah it's definitely hulk for sure uh 39
the big question how will they introduce
the mutants we've been asking ourselves
this every
pretty much every other video i don't
know
um uh probably through the multiverse
yeah there's probably gonna be some huge
event that happens that triggers
everybody's late mutant gene i don't
know what's gonna hap how it's gonna
happen maybe in an avengers 5 scenario
but like hopefully it's very soon
because i do miss my bald buddy
professor xavier on my screen yeah
question 40 who should be the first
mutant to show up in the mcu who do you
think empty
i mean it's gotta be my girl jubilee i
say bringing jubilee in the marvels i
think jubilee would fit very well on the
marvel's team with uh the three other
ladies it would be so great just because
like her light powers just match up well
with all of the spectrums light powers
and captain marvel's live powers and
then she could be buddies with miss
marvel and they could geek out about
nerd stuff together i think it'd be
great
yeah jubilee it's a hard question to
answer because uh there might already be
mutants in the mcu like you know wanda
maximoff could be a mutant in the mcu i
love the idea i love how the the earlier
film started with magneto with eric
lynch or his origin story i think that's
fun i
don't think it should be wolverine um i
kind of want it to be like someone weird
like phoenix force or you know jean grey
or something like that could be a fun
place to start and multiverse of madness
you know code let's get towed number one
yeah yeah yeah baby
uh 41 do you think marvel will do
anything with ursa major oh the the
russian bear from black widow no i don't
think i know i maybe for disney plus i
think disney plus is likely because i
feel like that's where they put their
you know their your that trucks and
those types they're not gonna spin off
that guy from black widow and no they're
not going to give him his own show like
they're definitely not giving him his
own show but like they'll probably make
him an element in like maybe like a
thunderbolt or some type of deal i don't
even think they're going to bring that
guy back i think that was just a
reference to that movie and that actor's
like i'm the first mutant in the mcu i
did it
no i think that guy's done they might
bring they might recast or some major in
some future thing but it's not gonna be
him a 42 who should they cast as
wolverine um
i don't know
some i i want a short dude i just want a
short buff man i don't care who it is i
just want the correct height because i
like a short wolverine yeah maybe you
could do uh luke hemsworth he's pretty
good right
i don't know
i want an unknown go out to some uh
playhouse in like edmonton or uh
somewhere in alberta and find just like
whoever the gruffest angriest guy in the
cast is and just have him audition i bet
like pick an unknown don't pick someone
that we already know like this is my
thing about like who would you cast
everyone always ask that question be
like who from movies that i already know
do you want to see in this other role
it's like i want an unknown hugh jackman
was a relative unknown when he was cast
as wolverine surprise us you know that's
what i want well i'm gonna uh i'm gonna
go against that and i'm gonna say corbin
blue from the high school music series i
think that he would make a really great
wolverine his ferocity
uh during uh i don't dance really shook
me to my car
so yeah it's corbin blue well the good
news is
wolverine can be as old as you want them
to be because they're kind of an ageless
person right so they don't have to be a
kid they can be a man in his 50s it can
be a really old man it could be clint
eastwood cleaning sweat is for free
there you go old man logan uh 43 tea or
coffee
coffee brit get back into your eyes i
miss coffee my stomach is sensitive
these days because i'm 29 and old so i
can't drink coffee so i uh i have to go
to tea and yeah i miss coffee whatever
you're from boston you guys dump tea in
the harbor i know we do and like we live
off coffee dunkin donuts is in our life
blood and i just can't drink it it's so
sad all right uh i only drink coffee i
sweat coffee you know those old gatorade
ads that's me but
just sweating brown
[Laughter]
uh 44 beach or mountains i grew up in
florida i love the beach but i moved to
california and i love the mountains here
so i gotta go mountains
i'm gonna go
my bedroom just kidding no a beach beach
is more so my speed mountains ah not for
me it's good of heights yeah and
climbing oh yeah mountains aren't for
you 45 if you could make an mcu movie
about a villain which one do you think
it
would be best suited again i got to go
dr doom i think doctor i think we just
need a movie called doom
but doctor doom daddy watch it i really
want to make a movie about black cat and
white rabbit from the spider-man
universe i really think white rabbit is
a really underused character so i think
that those two would have a really fun
time 46 which superhero protagonists do
you think had the biggest impact or
influence on pop culture
i mean
i don't know you talk about historically
in comics superman batman spider-man
like the big names have had a lot of
influence on pop culture and and that so
many other comics would not exist
without them and and the biggest movies
in hollywood would not exist without
people like this
uh but protagonist um uh jesus christ my
friend
greatest story ever told what's that
bible open read the verses to me back
i would say hmm
maybe captain kirk even though no that's
not a superhero i'm not going to say
that yes he is i'd be kind of cause like
i'm just thinking the star trek shows
and like how they you know just affected
everything and how like the doors from
star trek became real and all that stuff
oh yeah maybe that's kind of a cheap
answer though
no it's a good answer the trekkies feel
well respected and i think that was a
good answer um 47 how far do you think
the mcu can go 10 years 20 or more uh
well it's already been more than 10
years
so at this point we're getting closer
and closer to 20 i think we can go 30
years i think it's just always gonna be
around yeah the mcu is going to go on
forever but i think the true like the
spirit of the mcu will probably
leave whenever kevin feige goes i feel
or if they can get you know a very
equivalent creative leadership then like
i feel like that's when the mcu might
start to dip in quality because kevin
feige really cares about that universe
and like that's why it's as amazing as
it is i feel i mean what's crazy though
is if you look at like the bond
franchise it's been around over it's
about 50 years now and while it's gone
through different evolutions and
different eras like it still kind of
references itself like there's been
different specters but like i think the
mcu can last as long as bond has as long
as there are screens to depict these
stories
yeah like empty's gonna go
there's no way there's going to die 48
do you think the multiverse is the
explanation for the stanley appearances
in the mcu um i don't think the
multiverse per se but he could be
implied to be like the one above all or
something like that i think that they're
just never going to explain it and i
hope they never explain it i just think
that it's just a fun thing that they do
it's just like breaking the wall it's
like hey i made all these characters and
i can just do what i want i love it
uh 49 have you guys found the missing
easter egg in guardians of the galaxy
uh not yet mt has gotten closer uh and
james gunn has sent us some nice
feedback saying that uh mt and then some
videos we have made have just you know
there's a whole discord community of
people who have uh done a lot of good
work trying to decode those coordinates
but it's something in those coordinates
we just don't know what the answer is
yet right it's coming i'm trying i'm
working on it
yeah uh 50 what in each of your opinions
is the funniest moment in mcu history
what do you think empty hmm
that's a really good question i don't
know i think get help
and thor ragnarok
that cracked me up i thought that was
great we are not doing get help
you can't help please my brother he's
dying get help help him
that was a classic moment i really like
and this might not be the funniest it's
definitely the funniest one when morris
appeared in shang tree like just like
the reaction to everybody just like not
expecting it she's like oh my god i
cracked up like oh my god it's a
faceless chicken i was not expecting
this it was just funny so now is the
perfect time to remind you all about the
best way to support our channel our
merch partners at epic hero shop have
all kinds of cool clothing and gear
inspired by your favorite properties so
keep an eye out for some very cool
eternals and hawkeye inspired designs
dropping in the very near future but in
the meantime grab a shang shirt or a
suicide squad sticker or whatever you
want shopping at new rockstars merch is
an awesome way to support the channel
and show the world your love for your
favorite fandom that's right near
exercisemerch.com and before we dive
into the rest of your questions some
words from the people help us bring a
big question to you thanks to our
friends at mit mobile for sponsoring
this episode big wireless providers love
to get you with a catch in their
contracts bit mobile secret sauce is
that there is no catch they're the first
company to sell wireless service online
only there's no crazy overhead costs
that get passed down to you and this
form mystery fees instead mint just
passes on sweet savings direct to you
here at the rockstars phillip switched
to mint mobile and loves it he has a
great service it's just awesome service
everywhere he goes saves a bunch of
money and he gets to keep his number for
people looking for extra savings mint
mobile offers premium wireless for just
15 bucks a month all plans come with
unlimited talk and text high speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network and if you're not 100 satisfied
mint mobile has you covered with their 7
day money back guarantee switch to mit
mobile and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month to get
your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month and get the plan shipped to your
door for free go to mobile.com bigq
that's mintmobile.com bigq cut your
wireless bill to just 15 bucks a month
at midmobile.com bigq we also want to
thank napjitsu for sponsoring this
episode lots of smart people like to
take naps like albert einstein thomas
edison they were famous nappers reed
richards and nick fury are fictional
characters but i bet if they were real
people they'd be taking naps to get
through those busy days with plenty of
energy well napjitsu is a new way to
recharge your body and your brain and
they are committed to changing the
culture around rest and napping
napjitsu's natural supplements were made
by people who know how it feels to be
tired and busy their patent-pending
formulas have natural ingredients like b
vitamins guarana and ginseng to give you
a boost of energy without the crash
later each napjitsu product provides
brain boosting new tropics to unlock
steady energy right when you need it the
result your peak performance all day
long nap jitsu supplements are packaged
into small packets so you can take them
wherever and whenever you might need an
energy boost whether you need to
experience deeper sleep or unlock
immediate lasting energy remember the
smart rest more the wise rest better
rest up and level up with nabjitsu for a
limited time receive 30 off your first
purchase when you go to napjitsu.com big
question that's napjitsu.com bigquestion
for 30 off your first purchase today
that's n a p j i t s u dot com slash big
question all right empty we're gonna get
back into this we're gonna go as fast as
we can are you ready all right 51 an end
game how did banner get the hulkbuster
armor to thanos's garden planet the
benatar did not look like it had room to
fit all of that and i doubt stark
satellites can jump through wormholes i
just think it did fit on the benatar the
benefit's a bigger ship than you think i
mean i think the hulkbuster armor is
only like 12 feet tall you just lay it
on its side yeah there's definitely room
in that ship it's big enough 52 why did
it say eight years later in springtime
homecoming because sony gave a stupid
note and committed yeah it was a stupid
mistake and no one caught it very weird
53 when steve left his double date with
bucky to try enlisting uh one more time
did bucky definitely maybe 100 take both
girls quote to the end of the line on
his last night before deployment hell
yes but uh 100
that's sebastian stan so uh yeah respect
and know the name
sebastian can withstand two girls
54 who gets it on the most of the mcu uh
seems like either peter quill or tony
starks seem to
get around the most i'mma say wong i
think wong yeah he'd be slang in it
he's hanging it all over the world you
might be right uh 55 what if a character
has children with their variants
yeah don't do it i would uh advise
against it uh some people call me a
bigot but uh
i don't believe in varian and variant uh
yeah i'm okay with them dating or even
uh
just having i mean i just say i don't
know i guess they don't care it's never
gonna exist in the real world so who
cares yo who knows if if loki and sylvia
have a baby the internet will collapse
they will not be happy with that
maybe a variant in variance offspring is
just like a nexus being who just kind of
like exists in out of in and out of
realities and they yeah they're not even
human anymore 56 who who's the next big
name mcu character to die
[Music]
in guardians um definitely gonna happen
in guardians hey they were teasing that
maybe we could see ant-man die by kang i
know that some news came out and they
were like maybe i don't know you're
gonna have to watch i'm thinking maybe
mordo like multiverse of madness
someone's probably gonna die in
multiples of madness i would imagine
right but i i would say in terms of
guardians we might see drax go i think
drax is uh jay bush might be done
yeah yeah
57 when cap goes back in time are there
two caps in that timeline the one in the
ice the one that we know that went back
no i think there was two uh branch
timelines i don't subscribe to what
those screenwriters were saying 58 so
back to the future was a bunch of bs no
scott lang was wrong
[Laughter]
their movies rules were essentially back
to the future part two so back to the
future is an amazing movie it's one of
my favorite all-time films so no it was
not a bunch of bs back to the future it
never was it's literally uh sci uh
literal science 100 that's uh yeah the
time
i know it seems wacky but that's
actually how it works yeah uh 59 is
steve rogers currently alive in the mcu
i believe yes
yeah he's somewhere on there somewhere
but yeah yeah
60 did cap get the get a soul back when
he returned the soul stone to vormir the
screenwriters say no that it's not like
an exchange again you just kind of put
it back in its place and it's not like
you get natasha back or anything i think
that would be complicated if he got
because he would just get a random soul
back of someone else who was sacrificed
in the past yeah i think the sacrifice
thing in uh in infinity war and end game
was the soul stone trying to have the
person prove that they were worthy of
getting the soul stone so like it isn't
like oh you'll get it back it's like no
prove to me that you you could get this
by sacrificing a soul so right yeah it's
not an exchange i think it's yeah yeah
yeah 61 when hulk snaps an end game who
do you think he saw we know tony c's are
growing up morgan thanos he's a young
gamora who or what does hulk see i think
hulk saw natasha that would be my thing
i would love if hulk saw the maestro
somehow because we did see well in the
deleted scene or whatever that he tony
did see a grown up morgan so like maybe
he sees a future version of himself he's
just like i'm coming i'm like that's
crazy that shit's gonna happen
i don't know 62 what would groot do with
the infinity stones that's an
interesting question i think he would um
branch off and try to separate them as
far apart from each other as they can it
would it would just probably make more
video games i think he'd just make more
video games with his uh infinity stone
powers he's just a very uh he's a
teenage boy just does whatever teenage
boy oh you're thinking like how would he
use him i was thinking like how would he
like prevent others music that's a good
that's probably the question yeah
you're right i think he would just
create more video games uh 63 would
group make good firewood how dare you
god how dare you ask that question
probably oh my god how do you answer
that question is sauron asking that
question after burning all the ants
64. which are some of the characters you
think will turn out to be scrolls and
secret invasion i don't know i i i think
howard stark maybe thaddeus ross some of
these government figures who've just
been around for a long time i think that
maybe uh tony stark's mom was replaced
by a squirrel at one point because like
we don't really know much about maria
stark and like they could just easily do
that for their character so yeah maybe
she's still around somewhere maybe she
didn't really die and bucket killed a
scroll i used to think sharon carter was
the likeliest but then they kind of like
ruined her character by making the
power broken crocodiles i don't know
who knows she could still be a squirrel
who knows they could easily just be like
oh that wasn't sharon let's just make
her even crazier yeah uh 65 why is the
cop dad from ant-man a scroll
i reject the premise of your question i
don't think we know he's a scroll
um i think he'd be an interesting option
as a scroll but we don't know for sure
if he is i would yeah that's definitely
a huge candidate because you can do
anything with that character i mean it
doesn't really matter he's not really
biologically related to cassie so yeah
make him a squirrel anyone who like can
be a squirrel without screwing too much
in the mcu should be a scroll i think
that's the rule of secret invasion 66
where is galactus he's right behind you
67. michael is the sixth member of the
sinister six um
i like to think kingpin i think
kingpin's a good choice um but i think
we'll see someone else crossover maybe
like the rhino or something like that oh
my god i really want to see prowlers so
i have my fingers props for donald
glover 68 does santa exist in the mcu
yeah uh clint barton just ran him over
in the hawkeye trailer
santa confirmed 69 what are the behind
the scenes of new rockstars like how
many people are on the team oh
okay let's see there's a lot of us we're
kind of spread out all over the country
empty you're in boston we got it our
editor josh is in uh tennessee
uh we got other editors in pennsylvania
i think full time there's like what 10
of us now i think we just grew a lot in
the past yeah we're slowly growing um
yeah slowly growing and still growing
hopefully we'll be able to add some more
people to the team over the next year we
got a whole bunch of like freelancers
and contractors who work with us i think
it's about like eight to ten full-time
and then double that contractors who
work with us behind the scenes it's very
fun it's like we all just like joke
around and like we genuinely love what
we do so it just feels like i don't know
it just feels like a bunch of nerds just
doing nerd
we often talk about whenever we uh join
like these uh remote calls or right
before we shoot something like we would
just be able to release this chit chat
as a podcast
talk about whatever the hell they want
as opposed to making stuff that's super
you know uh algorithm friendly answering
the questions people are asking that's
what we do here at new rockstars
obviously but i'd love to just have like
a shoot in the podcast it would be
so like the things that we say before we
shoot are hilarious like you guys miss
out on so much hilarious conversations
well some of it's for the best some of
it should never slow down it should
never air ever
70. where does the channel name come
from uh new rock stars used to be called
new media rock stars it was a website
doing journalism about uh youtubers and
influencers uh and just covering
internet culture so it was the rock
stars of new media was the idea that new
media rock stars uh but then as uh
philip came in and took over the youtube
channel he was kind of the creative
producer for that he realized we weren't
really doing that kind of stuff anymore
we were like kind of doing more film
analysis so he had this idea of just
like taking out the media just making it
new rock stars yeah i believe his idea
you have to ask him more about it but i
think his premise was like what are what
is what is the idea of being a rock star
these days it's like a trailer that
drops can be a rock star the spider-man
no way home trailer was a rock star just
like any kind of big meme that blows up
can be a rock star so that's kind of
like we just focus on the things that
that the internet cares about at any
given moment 71 favorite thing about
your job um being able to host up with
mt
same here i was just about to say my
friends so you stole my answer yes i
love all my co-workers especially you
eric it's great
we got a great team here i think it's
the company is the best part of it um 72
where's phil molina and what has eric
done with him i have not done anything
with philip uh phillip has a weird um
ability to transcend the laws of space
and time and that there's kind of a
heisenberg uncertainty principle that
governs where philip is at any given
moment if he ever tried to locate him he
will immediately teleport somewhere else
and the act of observing him will uh
change his nature in some form exactly i
cannot really answer where he is i
honestly don't know where he is right he
kind of has like a nick fury thing about
him he's just like you don't really know
what he's doing but you know he's doing
something important
73 do you want pinocchio nipples that's
all what
um absolutely just kidding what are you
what is that question um it means if
your nipples start lying they get hard
and longer wow why would anybody want
that i don't want my nipples to be able
to lie
what is the evolutionary advantage of
pinocchio their nipples i don't know i
mean what is the evolutionary advantage
of nipples on men at all it's not about
evolution there's no fitness survival uh
darwinian boy breasts decoy breath to
trick the baby
trick the baby 74 if you were uh to be
free from the matrix what would your
alias be and what would you be known for
doing when you're jacked in
uh making youtube videos i think i am in
the matrix right now
uh and i think outside of the matrix uh
it would be like
surge protector or something
stupid i would probably
uh steal uh ready player one because i'm
all about easter egg so i'll probably
call myself parzival i think it'd be fun
75 other than hulk which avenger has the
largest head i guess the watcher is not
an avenger so he doesn't count
um i think doctor strange is a pretty
big noggin i would say so he's got a
pretty big uh is he not an avenger
yeah he's an avenger i guess he's an
associate yeah
wong is a pretty big head 76 what is
hulk's weakness um lullabies sun's
getting real low
yeah i think his weakness was natasha
romanoff like real talk and like now
that she's gone he's probably gonna go
crazy which could lead us to our world
war hook scenario that was just rumored
77 what is the most difficult show or
movie to find easter eggs in um you
mentioned parzival and i got triggered
because ready player won i hated
hated breaking down that movie and i
didn't really like the movie that much
i'm kind of pissed off at ready player
one because i think it's an amazing
concept but ernest cline doesn't ever
critique the idea of being obsessed with
pop culture he celebrates it in this
kind of like gross way that feels out of
touch with himself like i would love
ready player one if at the end like
first of all were to realize he lost out
on all of his relationships like if he
found out if this was like a toxic thing
he was doing to gunt like it just felt
like a missed opportunity so the and
it's the exact kind of movie that i hate
like i hate how studios now specifically
warner does this a lot like space jam
new legacy just make movies as easter
egg vehicles and put in the flintstones
or iron giant somewhere in the
background and it's just like annoying
it's not fun to break down those movies
it's like that's what
that space jam trailer really uh took
out took a lot out of me it was just a
trailer good god the real reason for the
season is to celebrate the resurrection
of one of the most wholesomely righteous
icons of all time space jam
and it's not even easter eggs when you
could it's just like put it in as a
reference it's a bunch of warner stuff
that they put in for a cash grab stupid
but everyone tweets us be like why
aren't you breaking this down it's full
of easter eggs i'm like because that's
it's a stupid kind of movie like it's
not fun to find easter eggs in that um
what is your favorite movie to find
easter eggs in now this is a good
question my favorite kind of movie
tonight easter eggs and are ones that
are not like superhero genre movies i
think it's more rewarding like knives
out was one of the most fun movies to
find and i don't even like calling them
easter eggs just details just production
details like uh filmmaking details like
little clues you know i'm way more
interested in finding easter eggs there
than i am and looking at license plates
in a spider-man movie see i i only like
looking at easter eggs in marvel
cinematic universe stuff because like
because i know that there is a universe
that is being crafted and that there is
a lot of care being taken specifically
um with like a lot of attention to
detail i'm just i'm just like i'm trying
to look for those little elements that
connect together that hopefully tell
this like huge overrocking cosmic story
so that's pretty much i i just love mcu
easter eggs in particular yeah i i like
that i liked like uh uh get out uh
jordan peels get out like we never did a
breakdown of that but like that's a fun
movie there he puts a ton of little
there's so much symbolism in that movie
like yeah i i much prefer a movie like
that or like the shining i know i
mentioned like horror films here i think
there's way more opportunities to like
really do stuff that tell a story with
the details with the attention to detail
as opposed to like i just want to
reference a specific comic issue where
doc is in it that's not rewarding to
find to me yeah it's just kind of like
all right like whatever 80 are wong and
strange breaking up why does one of a
suitcase he can sling rings to his
closet from wherever whatever
good point he can reach into his closet
i don't think they're breaking up i just
think he's visiting camara touch yeah i
think he's just like he just wants a
break we were on a break and he's just
like you know what we have our intern uh
the guy who's sweeping the snow so
you'll take care of it they're not
married they can have separate lives
it's totally fine they're not breaking
right right right
uh 81 could mordo be working with
mephisto everyone is working with
mephisto they just don't know it yet 82
superman vs doctor strange who would win
i mean if doctor strange has the ability
to warp reality doctor strange like
again i don't like these i don't get
these questions like their superman's
powers comes from the earth's sun if
there's no sun in a universe does
superman lose his power can dr strange
manifest kryptonite where everyone you
know it's just kind of like
we're not even talking about the
characters fighting each other anymore
we're talking about the rules of their
universe and that's why i don't like
these crossover questions like i don't
care
i'm sorry i'm getting mad i don't know
i'm getting so mad
well i would say dr strange but if if if
superman had the like if if he knew he
had the balls dr strange was and he had
the balls to kill him the superman in
like a split second juana maximov versus
gene gray who would win now i like this
question same universe right i think
jean grey if she's fully phoenix force
powered up might have more control
uh maybe not as much control now that i
mentioned it i don't know i think i mean
scarlet witch is supposed to be more
powerful than jean grey i guess i mean
when it comes to the house of m events
no one is more powerful than scarlet
witch so i guess scarlet witch gets the
edge there ah man i i don't know i would
say the phoenix force is pretty up there
in power yeah um they're both omega
level
yeah i would say jean grey okay uh 84
who would win in a fight zombie thanos
versus thanos i think zombie thanos
right um
i don't know
thanos has tough skin as it is so like a
bite would be kind of rough so like i
think zombie thanos has stones right
you're saying neither of them are you
removing the infinity stones from the
equation yeah i would say okay i'm
removing the infinity stones i would say
regular thanos would uh find a way to
beat zombie thanos because he's rotten
away he's running away 85 if thanos said
dusted wolverine and deadpool would they
be permanently dusted yeah i think so i
think they can regenerate but the
infinity stones outweigh their ability
to regenerate they're kind of being
erased from existence 86 could thanos
snap the watcher um no i think the
watcher's uh above he's outside of our
universe so i don't think he yeah would
be snapped yeah the snap only covered
that particular universe who's the
smartest mcu character i would guess
shuri
i mean i think dr strange i think dr
strange like the fact that he just has
all this knowledge he has like
photographic memory
i think he's smarter actually that's a
really good point because magical
knowledge is just knowledge and it's not
a different type of knowledge so yeah
it's probably strange i mean he seemed
to uh master like medicine like physical
medicine physical science and then now
he has like another form of the dance
science magic yeah i don't know 88 how
likely is it that we see the beyonder
and the secret wars arc in the mcu i
don't know if we'll see the beyonder per
se i think it's likely but i think we
will for sure see secret wars in the
next couple years
i think that we might get hints at the
beyonder because we do have hints at the
builder race who are these super
primordial creatures who um
are tied into the uh the whole secret
wars event so maybe we might see them
but like beyonders i don't know 89 uh
you can only see one again in the mcu
chris evans or robert downey jr um hmm
i'd have to go with chris evans i think
chris evan seems like more of a team
player more of an ensemble member uh
robert downey jr is a rock star he's
great but uh
like it seems like chris evans can kind
of fit in a lot of different scenarios
so i like chris evans there's one thing
that will always give you an edge
a hot lunch i i would say chris evans
because of that you know the way that
end game ended and it just doesn't seem
like his story is fully done so i do
want to see what he was up to while he
was you know delivering those stones
back but i do want to see robert downey
jr maybe either as a mephisto or a uh a
squirrel in like a secret invasion type
thing i think it'd just be fun
with uh peter parker's emotions it would
be great yeah uh 90. which mcu character
would you most enjoy playing uh mojo i
think mojo would be fun to play
i really want to play this bear on this
team called brute force it's a team of
animals and like they're just animal
avengers essentially and i want to play
the bear one because i love bears 91
favorite movie of all time alien
[Music]
dang
i think i'm gonna go with her that's a
good one i love that movie
92 which non-dc or non-marvel comics
need movies oh my god that's a great
question um i love valiant comics i
don't know if you guys know this about
me but valiant comics are one of the
best superhero comics out there like if
you don't read valentine's go rebellion
comics i've been dying for a harbinger
movie so badly and also archer and
armstrong movie and ivar time so many go
read valiant comics they're fantastic
ninja too ninja oh yeah my answer is
ninja sorry i just got really excited
the end
how about uh saga that sounds great
movie um 93 empty you can answer this
where did omni man go yeah i i think
omniman went to go have a baby with
another uh lady i forget oh to start
over it's been a it's been a while but
he does i know he does have a kid with
another lady at some point so he's off
on another planet just trying to be a
good boy
alert
uh 94 favorite non-superhero show on
netflix um right now squid game
i like ozark a lot
uh stranger things obviously it's really
fun
yeah i just finished alice in borderland
if you have a hole in your heart from
squid game alice in borderland will fill
that hole it is literally
very much like squid game a lot of very
messed up games that play with your
emotions so alice in borderland season
two is coming uh 95 is die hard a
christmas movie yes
i hate i really truly hate this question
who gives a at this point watch it
at christmas if you want
this is just a question that people like
to ask to feel uh cool what if you think
it's a christmas movie it's a christmas
movie who cares sure yeah uh 96 one word
to describe the last season of game of
thrones rushed didn't watch it 97 what's
your relationship status engaged and
extremely happy
just kidding oh it's empty yes while i'm
here i'm here i'm engaged
i am very much single um ready to mingle
you heard it folks help this man out
uh let's see you guys are gonna ride
with rick and morty until the wheels
fall right uh
um
dub correct
yeah hell yeah we are
uh 99 where do you go from here
uh
right now i'm gonna shoot some brand
spots for future videos uh gonna try to
watch a new episode of succession and
then we're going to go watch dune i mean
am i poop in a few hours i don't know
what a lot of options
in terms of new rock stars i guess to
answer your question for the channel
we're going to be making a lot more of
everything gonna give you a little bit
of everything all the time oh yeah or a
lot of everything all the time and we've
made it to our 100th question and it is
our box scraps question
who was the first superhero who inspired
you i would have to say
even though it's kind of late in the
game captain america like uh the mcu
version of america specifically after
winter soldier um because that's when my
love of the mcu really just like went
into high gear because that movie was
phenomenal and like i just loved the way
that he just stood up for what he
believed in no matter what and i was
just like damn and he was just a good
man and like i just feel like there's
not a lot of
celebration of good men or just good
people in general and i think that
that's why i love captain america that's
why i love vision it's just that they're
just good people i mean as a kid i loved
batman and superman equally uh like i
watched those movies i watched the
animated series i had pajamas for both
of them my favorite pajamas were
superman pajamas that had a cape to them
um i think the first one that actually
like inspired me in terms of like my
personality was probably wolverine from
the x-men animated series because i
remember going to preschool
uh in kindergarten and pretending to be
wolverine and just walking around like
this by myself through the schoolyard
because i was i'm kind of an introvert i
don't i don't really feel comfortable in
large crowds so like as a kid i would
always just go play by myself and i
would literally just stalk
the playground
yeah exactly i like it on the animated
series wolverine would always go alone
like cyclops would pitch some some plan
some battle strategy and wolverine's
like yeah whatever bub and just go off
and do his own thing and then he would
meet up with everyone at the end and
they'd all hang out professor exec
professor xavier would be like i'm very
proud of all of you and i'm like as long
as i can have dinner with everyone at
the end of the day that's all i care
about right i loved where that wolverine
would like just break strike ops like
cars or motorcycles before he left he's
like you just like yeah that's right
yeah i love it well we did it we got
through 100 questions
we want to thank everyone who submitted
questions for our 100th episode we could
not have done it without you once we get
to 200 we'll do 200 questions oh god
let's do it
we'll be old men by then uh so we want
to thank you all for joining us this
episode a big question thank you to
empty uh for joining me this episode
follow mt at mastertainment follow me at
eavos follow new rockstars here on
youtube and on all social media
platforms and make sure to hit that
notification bell bye bye everybody love
you guys bye
[Music]
you